hired extra security after cutting
hundreds of Staff members
uh this is a Daily Mail story let me go
to the story here so CNN CEO Chris Licht
reportedly hired extra security to stand
outside the conference room and follow
him around after cutting Network staff
licked laid off hundreds of employees
including some big name on-air talents
like preet bahara Alison acoustic Dan
Merica and Chris silza late had sat in
the executive conference from throughout
the day with the doors open to take
questions from remaining employees about
the string of cuts While most of the
cuts were off-camera employees
contributors producers and reporters
like Martin Salvage Marianne Fox and
Alex field also faced layoffs and also
are now forced to look for employment
elsewhere another major casualty of
licked Cuts was CNN spin-off HLN and its
entire step that's why the lady was
crying so what are your thoughts on this
Tom well I think
we are such an angry people right now
that uh a CEO that's brought in to
combination to a turnaround and part of
that he has to wield the hatchet on
staff
um it's not surprising to me and I think
it's very
prudent that he did this but is
completely unsurprising we are such an
angry people right now and you're laying
off a bunch of folks I applaud the fact
that if it is true that he was in the
conference room he was taking questions
so it sounds like he's trying to
communicate it hey there's no good way
to say this we're s we we are not
getting uh good Advertiser response this
was not done out of pettiness this was
not done out of preference this was how
this was done out of a lack of profit
and there's no money to pay these people
so he had to make changes including some
large contracts that apparently people
that weren't pulling viewership so I I
look at it and say you may not like what
it looks like America but this was a
business decision and it and if it is
true I applaud that he at least tried to
have a dialogue with people but the fact
we are so angry and we are so on edge
you know you know he had to get security
and I understand that you know you know
what's interesting about this this
happens every large organization goes
through this but you know what happened
with Twitter when Twitter laid off 37 3
500 people it was cover story everywhere
he's a terrible man but when CNN does it
it's a different story right think about
how they have to spend the way they're
letting people go versus how when
Twitter store every other second they
were talking about Elon Musk let's go 3
500 people Elon Musk let's go 3 500
people and then you're doing this FYI
John Malone
I think you said
you want to go back to journalistic
Integrity you said that okay these are
your words you said you want to take CNN
back to Real by the way is there audio
cut up do you hear my audio
I think you guys are good mind sums
happen with mine if the audio is if the
if the audience is not hearing anything
going on my audio then it's just my mic
it's fine but I hear something going on
with my mic but if John if you're
talking about you really want to do that
to CNN and you're really committed to it
can I ask you why you haven't yet
covered this Twitter story there has to
be conference calls with leaders at the
top or are you like when the stories at
Twitter the story didn't come up to Jack
Dorsey because maybe he wasn't involved
during those times maybe he was off site
and you don't think the Twitter story
needs to be told by your people what do
you think you think the fake news
labeled that CNN God is gradually going
away or you think you're increasing it
by actually not talking about what was
just released this past Saturday by
Twitter documentation not opinions
screenshots of Email exchange there is
nothing more real than an email coming
from a person telling you what they're
asking somebody of an organization like
Twitter to do and you still haven't
covered it so guess what CNN you are
still fake news and until you're willing
to do your part competing on both sides
telling doing journalism on both sides
unfortunately until that changes CNN is
still fake news till today hopefully
they'll do something about it because we
need competition in media I told this
thing about how all of us here use an
iPhone okay does anybody not use an
iPhone Rob tell us you don't use an
iPhone your iPhone this is terrible news
by the way that everybody uses iPhones
we need competition and media so people
are watching everybody we need it
everywhere this doesn't benefit if CNN
is not doing journalism anymore it does
not benefit it so you know when I see a
stat like this one criticism if you
criticize others for getting laid off
and you just did it yourself it's kind
of painful number two if you really say
you want to change turn things around
well maybe you start kind of talking
about some real stuff instead of just
fake fake fake I'm constantly I wonder
about his security were they armed
because I mean people have seen that I'm
probably like not anti-second Amendment
but ain't nobody there got a gun so they
were just a bunch of buff guys walking
around like we got you okay because this
guy um John Malone is who compared to
Chris Licht Chris Licht is a new CEO and
John Maloney's the billionaire yeah
he's the new Ted Turner he's the new
he's the Ted Turner is a Founder but
he's the new guy that owns and runs the
company since um since you're an odds
guy
um what percentage of CNN do you think
of what they disseminate is fake news
uh what percentage what they disseminate
is fake news right because it's not a
hundred percent it's not zero percent so
of of course same thing for Fox and I
mean for everyone of course it's not of
course an odds guy yeah I would I don't
know the exact number I'm not gonna sit
here and tell you it's fake news or it's
not I guess what I would say is more
um
lack of doing your job bias listen for
us we're not journalists you can call
the citizen journalism but opinion we
run businesses for a living we we run
come with this is a podcast we're going
to talk about a bunch of different
business stories today we're gonna have
laughters we're gonna entertain we're
going to educate we're going to
Enlighten we're going to talk about
entrepreneurship Capital that's what
we're gonna do and we're going to do
this every day that's what we're doing
with our company right
these guys their job is to tell us what
the hell is going on they get paid to do
investigative journalism and we're
getting none of that how many people are
sitting there investigating what's
really going on with Twitter with Hunter
Biden at CNN zero how many people were
investigating what happened with Russia
collusion everybody and ended up being
wrong do you realize how pathetic an
organization looks when they do that
credibility of CNN look at this this is
statista this is not anybody else zoom
in a little bit if you could zoom in a
little bit okay I mean very credible 23
somewhat credible 30 percent not
credible at all 12 percent not at all
credible twenty percent
heard of no opinion 13 never heard about
this I mean I don't know what's this Rob
scroll in or out scroll and so I go to
the left what's the second number 20 and
30 30 yeah so 50 of the country thinks
that they're very or somewhat reliable
53 53 47 by the way right and the other
half of the country says that they're
not very credible or not at all credible
which is kind of America it's kind of
America I'd like to see foxes but you
know you know what I would say again
with them if you go and you investigate
Russia and you told us we're not the
experts that that's what happened and it
was all fake you're criminals
your criminals you cause how many
unnecessary fights that that fake story
about Russia created my God how many
families yeah you're absolutely right I
do think that so for instance
um
who was he on the other day was it um oh
is Ari um pleasure Ari Fleischer and he
said I said give me someone who's
credible because this whole thing was
that journalism is very biased and he's
I liked the name he gave and he said
that Brett Bear at the you know five
o'clock six o'clock hour on Fox News
That's someone that he finds me very
credible I actually happen to like Brit
bear I've met Brett Baron person I took
a picture with them and gave him respect
I usually think that's the type of
person but then you know after seven
o'clock eight o'clock then you get into
the lower Ingram and Tucker so there is
a difference in this kind of it's by the
way the same thing with with you know
you have Wolf Blitzer and you have uh
Jake Tapper who I also find to be pretty
credible and then you get into the Don
Le Mans and you get into you know the
Anderson Coopers so there is a major
difference between newsmen newscasters
even journalists to that regard and
opinion journalists and I think that
that's there's like this conflated sense
of like
well it's all kind of it's on CNN so
it's all intertwined or it's all [ __ ]
what's my point is that I think on
certain shows opinion shows there should
be
sort of a disclaimer that this is Don
lemon's opinion I agree this is Tucker
Carlson's opinion versus someone like
Brett Bear or someone like
um Shepard Smith or someone like Jake
Tapper where it's like this is the news
because you can't treat the same equally
just like how you kind of gave us like
listen we're business people we're doing
a podcast here we're not the news we're
not the journalists so there's a the
people understand that this is an
opinion by the way you do not agree you
asked for Fox's score here's foxes it
was 58 Fox is 58 CNN is 53. okay I'm
saying what I can't see so good no no
you you asked for the question they're
very credible and the somewhat credible
foxes 58 CNN was 53. so fox has got the
CNN beat by five percent so America
trusts Fox News more than they trust CNN
by five percent that's a big percent
that's ten percent more that's and
that's not a small percentage you're
talking about when it comes down to
percentages I give them you know I would
I would respect them more if they just
had to whoever's in charge now just to
be like hey guys look right in the
camera I'm like we we [ __ ] up we're
sorry try to be better what I'm saying
is then people might kind of chip
because like you say Adam it's not
objective journalism they're political
activist and I get it I'm pretty sure
the DNC gives money to CNN right and the
Republican Party hooks up Fox but why is
why is the fox winning why are they
killing stuck at Carlson number one and
killing it is it just that many more
Republicans out there so what all the
craziness taking place I believe future
looks right if you believe future looks
bright get your latest Future looks
bright hat of valuetaining it says
future looks right here future looks
bright here we got them in white we got
them in Black we got them in red are
black on black sold out these are about
to sell out if you haven't ordered one
yet we had a person in Michigan but one
then he bought three then when those
three people weren't in the office they
had to order 58 of them because people
wanted the future looks bright hat
especially during times like this
because ain't nobody's saying future
look spread toward your future looks
bright hat click over here and to watch
the entire podcast click here take care
everybody
foreign